So, I'm going to talk about the Phase I first-in-human dose escalation results from the TRIGNITE-1
study evaluating ISB2001, and this was initially presented at ASCO 2025, this data.
So key characteristics of ISB2001, this is a BCMA, CD38, and CD3 tri-specific antibody
with higher affinity targeting of BCMA and CD38 to enhance civility to myeloma cells
and lower affinity binding to CD3 with the goal of minimizing off-tumor toxicity and
T-cell exhaustion.
The dose escalation portion of this study evaluated 9 dose levels going up to 2700 micrograms
per kilogram.
Okay.
Key eligibility for this study included patients with 3+ prior lines of therapy who were triple
class exposed.
Prior CAR-T and/or Bispecific therapy was allowed, with the washout required to
be 3 months for CAR-T and 28 days for prior Bispecific therapy.
ISB2001 was administered as a subcutaneous injection once weekly following initial step-up doses.
And data presented here is from the dose escalation portion of the study for the initial 35 patients
who had at least 1 month of follow-up at the time of data cut-off.
The median follow-up for these patients was 6.3 months.
Baseline characteristics, the median number of prior lines of therapy was 6, 49% of patients
were triple class refractory.
And um, 46% of patients had prior exposure to BCMA-directed therapy, including 7 patients
with prior BCMA bispecifics, 7 patients with prior BCMA antibody drug conjugate, and 4 patients
with prior BCMA-directed CAR-T therapy.
Extramedullary disease was present in 34% of patients at screening, and 40% of patients
had high-risk cytogenetics.
ISB2001 was associated with a manageable safety profile.
There were no DLTs observed across the full dose escalation.
CRS events were mostly low-grade, with 57% grade 1 CRS and 11% grade 2 CRS.
And this mostly occurred after the first step-up dose, with a median time to onset of 2 days
and median duration of 2 days.
13 patients received tocilizumab for CS, and there was no prophylactic tocilizumab administered.
One patient developed grade 1 ICANS, but there were no other drug-related neurologic
AEs.
There was one grade 5 cardiac arrest that was deemed not related to study treatment.
This was in a patient with significant cardiovascular history.
And then in terms of hematologic toxicity, grade 3 or higher neutropenia and thrombocytopenia
were seen in 43% and 23% of patients respectively, and 14% of patients had grade 3 or higher
anemia.
And in other patients, grade 3 or higher occurred in 29% of patients.
Responses were observed starting at dose level 3, with an overall response rate among all
patients in this cohort of 74%, but among patients treated with effective dose levels,
the response rate overall was 79%, with a 30% rate of CR or better.
This month, estimated duration of response was 90%.
And among 10 patients who had at least a CR, 8 of those were MRD-evaluable, and the rate
of MRD negativity by clonoseq was 75%.
Importantly, we also saw high responses among difficult-to-treat patient subgroups, so response
rates overall between 70% to 75%.
Among patients who had failed prior CAR-T or Bispecific therapy, patients who
had failed prior BCMA therapies, and patients who were refractory to CD38-directed therapies.
Additionally, the rate of response among patients with extramedullary disease at baseline
was 82%, and patients with high-risk cytogenetics, the overall response rate was 78%.
Pharmakinetic data was also encouraging.
With a dose-proportional PK profile and a median half-life of 17 days, supporting the evaluation of less frequent dosing intervals in dose expansion.
We also saw rapid reductions in soluble BCMA levels, as well as rapid increases in T-cell proliferation, even among patients who had received prior CAR-T and or Bispecific therapies.
So, ISB2001 demonstrates proof of concept for dual targeting of BCMA and CD38 and provides
early evidence that such an approach may help to overcome relapses driven by tumor heterogeneity
and antigen escape.
Efficacy also appears notable despite prior BCMA-directed therapy and prior T-cell redirecting
therapy exposure in many patients.
So, in conclusion, dose escalation was completed with no DLTs observed up to a dose of 2,700
micrograms per kilogram.
This drug was associated with a manageable safety profile with predominantly low-grade
CRS and minimal neurotoxicity, and we saw deep and durable responses at active doses
with an overall response rate of 79 percent, a CR or better rate of 60 percent.
And among evaluable patients, an MRD negativity rate of 75 percent, with a median duration
of response not reached.
We also saw robust activity across key subgroups, with efficacy seen regardless of prior CAR-T
exposure, T-cell engagers, and BCMA-directed therapies and CD38 refractoriness.
Dose expansion is ongoing to define the recommended phase 2 dose and future dosing strategies.
Thank you.
I'm sorry.